hi I'm miles teller and I'm in LA
shooting with GQ I would nominate my dad
Mickey T for Man of the Year one of his
kids to have everything and he always
put his wife first and you know his kids
before him and I think you know that's
really what it means to be a man woman
of the year I think you got a nominate
Beyonce because I saw her at the VMAs
and she was just like ridiculous man a
song of the years now it's not from this
year it's from the Grateful Dead and
it's sugary movie the year for me I
guess we're I mean I like what Wes
Anderson a lot so grand Budapest hotel
was really I just like Wes really brings
you into a world that is has been
reserved a lot of time for literature II
just bring to to this in a full
imagining rich world that it really
makes you kind of feel like a kid again
my TV show dears dating naked I think
it's a pretty bizarre show if I had to
go on a date naked
I would stop dating yes I don't know
it's a weird way to meet somebody the
funniest person years Jimmy Fallon I
think he's done a really good job of
kind of taking over for the The Tonight
Show villain of the years people who
don't recycle the villain every year my
friend on Facebook has a picture of a
really ugly baby and I think that's been
the funniest picture I've looked at all
year I could sum up the year in one word
it would be two words it would be
fantastic for biggest waste of time this
year's I don't know I just bought an
Xbox so I feel like I have a lot of time
to be wasted and that's that's gonna
start pretty soon this year I don't want
to go back to how I looked in February I
don't know what I was doing but it was
not trying very hard at life next year I
want to make some time to travel I
really hadn't had an opportunity to do
that in my life and I think that it's
really important I want to go to
Australia I want to go to Thailand
I'm gonna take my grandparents Island I
just went to Europe for the first time
and I was there for like three nights so
there's a lot of Europe that I want to
see if I had the opportunity to retire
and I you know and I was fine and
there's a lot of stuff like
you
you